but we begin with the Heartbreak in
Dadeville Alabama over that deadly mass
shooting where four young people were
killed officials now say 32 people were
hurt even more than previously realized
there are still no arrests and no word
on a motive but we do know what was lost
the four people who died our 23 year old
Corbin Holston 19 real 19 year old
Marcia Collins 17 year old Sean kevia
Smith an 18 year old Phil dowdell his
sister Alexis was celebrating her 16th
birthday that night Omar villafranca
spoke with Alexis dowdle and her mother
Latonya Allen who was shot twice Omar
good morning you were the first to speak
to this family is that right
that is correct and good morning the
family is in shock the mother says she
feels like her heart has been ripped out
Phil was about to graduate high school
next month and then off to play college
football at Jacksonville State but on
Saturday that bright future was taken
away from it
[Applause]
pandemonium late Saturday night it was
just as they were running Highland
crying gunshots sent dozens of teenagers
running from the dance studio where a
sweet 16 birthday party was being held
for LaTonya Allen's Daughter Alexis
dowdell Allen was struck twice I was
looking for um my two girls so both of
them came out
and then my daughter was saying what
field what field she says they found her
son Phil inside the dance studio Alexis
she got down on her knees and were
holding him he was just blood blood and
he was saying she was saying um you know
kept telling him wake up for you when
somebody from the ambulance had came in
and they fed his paws and it was like he
gone and nest and I was just like please
don't tell me that please don't tell me
that Phil dowdell was one of at least
four people killed along with fellow
High School senior Sean kivia Smith 19
year old marciah Collins and 23 year old
Corbin Holston video taken just minutes
before the shooting shows Alexis and her
brother wearing a pink hat dancing at
the party Alexis says when the bullet
started flying Phil pushed her to the
ground out of Harm's Way did your
brother save your life yes
if it wasn't for him
I mean I don't know where I'll be I
don't know if I'll still be standing
here today if he would never save my
life
there is still a lot we don't know about
the investigation but Alexis told me
that there were rumors that someone at
her party had a gun well her mom heard
about that and did what any mom would do
she stopped the party stopped the music
turned the lights on and told everyone
inside if you're over 18 and you have a
gun you need to leave later on that
night shots were fired Tony
terrible situation Omar thank you very
much